don't be afraid it's the Christmas
season and Christmas is really pushing
weird we're taught as young children to
believe in Santa Claus a fictitious
man's that gives us gifts once a year
and we're not allowed to ever see him
but at some point in our lives we find
out through some way or another that he
doesn't actually exist and this can be
an extremely sensitive and difficult
thing especially when there's someone in
your life that you feel like needs to
know that Santa does not exist and in
this modern era of strange social
interactions and almost non-existent
real-life human communication I'm gonna
tell them for you you even have to talk
to your kid or your friend or your wife
about this because I'm gonna do it for
you right here right now to the person
in your life that you want to let know
if Santa does not exist please ask them
to start watching this video right now
[Music]
three seconds after this ready dear you
look great and wanted me to talk to you
about something today something very
serious Santa Claus here's the thing
about Santa Claus it doesn't exactly
he's not real
completely fabricated and made up not a
real thing you know pranks for years
you're unbelievable
I took a dance break because I know this
news can be a lot to handle and I wanted
to distract you from the avalanche of
feelings you're about to feel let's get
into the nitty-gritty of this the brass
tacks of this you probably don't
understand either of those phrases but
you understand but the person I've sent
you this video has been lying to you
let's break this down they led you to
believe that there was a man living in
the North Pole talk about a house with
northern exposure HGTV joke do you watch
that child you are led to believe that
this man could see you when you were
sleeping he could see when you were
sleeping you don't have a Skype account
he would moderate your behavior
regularly you and the other 7 billion
people in the world he would decide if
you had been nice that year and would
give you a gift based on his decision or
instead give you cold no not calls not a
gift card to the wonderful affordable
department store chain called The Rock
not Dwayne the rock Johnson the lovable
charming and funnier than you might
think on social media wrestler turned
actor personality rock material science
you had adults telling you that you were
trying to make a list of the good kids
so that you could get gifts you'd be an
idiot not to believe that there are
books about this guy songs about this
guy movies about this guy there are
adults that dress up like this guy
and pretend to be this guy every year
you'd be an idiot not to believe this
you're not an idiot let's think about
some of this in hindsight to give you
some perspective child that Stacy in
your class she's been up tall a year to
you and everyone around her yes somehow
she got an iPhone 6 for Christmas
where's your Santa now every year your
parents tell you to put up cookies for
him the guy can afford his own cookies
he employs an entire factory 364 days a
year when your parents tell you that
you're not
from a dinner table because you didn't
finish your vegetables what would Santa
do Santa Claus is a sensitive subject
for a lot of people I understand that
and with this news you might be feeling
hurt to trade sad you may not believe me
and that's okay you should want to be a
good person because you want to be a
good person not because some fictitious
man decides if you're good and deserving
of something and for the people that led
you to believe that's the way to live
your life they owe you and the least
they can do is buy you my book for
credit crisis guide book calm this is
all been a plug for my book hey I don't
know granted the man knows how to
showcase a waistline with a cinched belt
I'll give him that
or whoever made up that fictitious
quality great job